let's get to some audience questions
first one is from Molly hey David what
Republican Party policies have actually
changed as a result of Donald Trump
either formally or implicitly I think
that that last part formally or
implicitly is a key part so number one
and that my mind immediately goes to
this we know that at the urging of Paul
Manafort and others days before the
republican national convention at which
donald trump would be crowned the
official nominee of the Republican Party
for the 2016 presidential election the
republican party platform when it comes
to Russia and Ukraine was changed and it
was softened towards Russia and it took
on a more not anti Ukraine position but
sort of a more indifferent to what
Russia is doing in Ukraine position so
that's number one number two this is
more implicit but Trump has sort of at
least talked differently about
infrastructure and kind of trade as well
and it hasn't really formally changed
the position of the Republican Party and
my guess is that if we eventually get
back to a sort of normal Republican or I
guess the the sort of Republicans we've
seen over the last 15 years that they
are not going to be big on
infrastructure spending like Donald
Trump has been even though again Trump's
version of infrastructure spending is a
very very crony capitalist handouts they
are not going to I would guess be all
about threatening and enacting tariffs
on steel and aluminum from both out from
allies and countries that we are engaged
in trade agreements with so I think that
those are more implicit ways in which
the Republican Party has kind of stood
aside and said hey he's the Republican
and will sort of work it out not formal
changes to policy I think the biggest
way in which Donald Trump has de facto
changed the Republican Party is the idea
of the moral high-ground right because
we have in the Republican Party a party
that is much more heavily religious than
the Democratic Party the religious the
most extreme
elements of American society tend to
vote Republican if they voted all
evangelicals being one of those groups
and they wanted to claim the moral high
ground for a very long time and they
still are sort of trying to claim it
with Donald Trump but not credibly so
right the guy who's had the affairs the
guy whose wife has posed nude the guy
who talked about grab him by the
you-know-what
the guy who I mean what you know became
anti-abortion when he was like 68 years
old after a full life of being in favor
of a woman's right to choose so I think
that in an unofficial capacity
the way that Donald Trump has most
changed the Republican Party is that
they no longer can even really claim the
moral high ground and that actually is
not just something to throw in their
faces and say you're hypocrites that
actually may allow really really
horrible and depraved candidates in the
future to do well in the Republican
Party because they'll say hey you know
what we are onboard with the these of
his these views of his or those views of
hers and we can ignore the moral
depravity and I think it sets a very
very dangerous precedent right well
really they were never able to claim the
moral high ground they just did anyway
ostensibly they attempted to yeah but
when it comes to policy I can't think of
anything post Trump that what will
change in the Republican party platform
I think everyone just identifies Trump
as an anomaly because it really a
Republican and you decided to run on
their party ticket so I don't think
anything will change going forward what
about when it comes to international
diplomacy like that's not it's not
policy but because of how Trump has
dealt in this sort of childish petulant
child way with the leaders of other
countries through Twitter it's not an
official change the Republican Party
policy but my guess is that other
Republicans and future Republicans will
feel like it's okay to sort of do
diplomacy in this totally non diplomatic
haphazard way that Trump has done it
well it's interesting so if we had a
Democratic president elected in 2020 and
then maybe a Republican won again 2024
yeah do you think China would see the
election of another Republican president
and think oh here come the tweets now I
don't I don't think the
no probably not it would depend on who
it is but I just worry that the party
would ignore just another wacky
candidate because they would say hey we
survived Trump and here like three
things he did that we like or something
like that attack yeah
tax cuts but that it's it's more or less
similar to what what we've seen and and
that's what they latch on to right they
say hey his tax cut bill was a pretty
it's what Republicans like to do so we
can ignore all the other stuff